[Music]
okay guys so i'm here in my kitchen
today
posting new sandwich making tutorials
dancing at a wedding this weekend with
boyfriend sam
eskari brittany's looking healthy and
happy but
her parents are in an ugly battle at
odds over her conservatorship
nothing in this case is normal yes it's
jamie versus lynn spears with jamie
claiming his
ex-wife is using britney quote lynn
spears is the one who exploited her
daughter's pain and trauma for personal
profit by writing a book about her
certainly listen it doesn't look great
on her perspective
you know and it could potentially be
looked at as unfavorably but i think
ultimately it's going to come down to
the legal intricacies of the case
she kind of really shut me out lynn sat
down with e.t in 2008 shortly after the
publication of that book through the
storm
lynn described a horrific incident at
the height of britney's troubles when
she was being rushed to the hospital
and i'm begging the ambulance please let
me ride
please let me go let me go with you i'm
her mom
and they tell me if you don't hush we're
going to restrain you
yes ma'am we don't really talk about
that time
the intense focus on the case comes
after the huge success of the framing
britney spears documentary
and now listen to this producers will
reportedly return with an
in-depth look at janet jackson's 2004
super bowl
wardrobe malfunction we thought it would
be cool instead of me just coming up by
myself to kind of mix it up with her
justin recently apologized to janet and
his ex brittany
after the britney dock examined how he
handled his split with the pop star he
essentially
weaponizes the video for one of his
singles to
incriminate her in the demise of the
relationship
and yeah that video has been viewed
nearly 400 million times wow